Joe Vardhan he is the NBA senior writer
for the athletic recent column in Kyrie
Irving's big moment with the Celtics
he's come to really feel for LeBron
James
Joe good morning how are you how are you
I'm doing fine I'm just curious what is
the game plan for the final couple of
weeks here for the LA Lakers is there a
chance with all these injuries that
maybe they sit down LeBron as well well
on the one hand you'd think so he's 34
years old he played 104 games last year
on to eight straight finals now is the
time to put him in mothballs as much as
you can and get him ready for what they
hope is a much much better year next
year but they have some problems with
this one is a fan problem you know it's
been a disaster of a year and LeBron he
he just hasn't quite connected in LA
within the organization and you know
with the fan base there and sitting him
down I think would would be a problem I
mean they're they have season season
ticket requested gone out they're asking
for a 16 percent increase so that's an
issue and then the other thing is just I
mean he is healthy and so you know
league rules kind of prevent this so I
could see it but I think it'll be a
little while before we get to that point
and maybe it'll just be more like he
doesn't play back the backs or maybe he
doesn't play a couple of road games yeah
I'm trying to figure that out though Joe
what can the league do or what would
they be aware of with a healthy scratch
from LeBron James yeah I mean and yeah I
guess you could say well he's aggravated
his groin or something to that effect
but I mean if you look at what's going
on with in New Orleans with with Anthony
Davis I mean they know he's healthy so
he plays doesn't play in the fourth
quarter I mean you can't you can't
litigate the minute that a guy plays but
they have basically dating back to a few
years ago when the cab
that LeBron Kevin and Kyrie from the
same game out in LA against the Clippers
basically from that day the league has
mandated that star players who are
healthy have to play so I you know well
what do they do to the Lakers in the
event that LeBron goes away I'm not sure
I just know that this is kind of been
the rule for the last couple years yeah
I'm trying to figure out this team as
they move forward let's say they don't
get Anthony Davis now do they have a
pretty good sample size with these
younger players that they know moving
forward that they're just temporary or
is is there somebody who could actually
survive the cut and not get traded by
the Lakers well Danny I mean this thing
over the weekend with Brandon Ingram is
a huge development huge and it's
obviously it's scary is anything for him
but beyond that I mean you can't trade
him now I mean who is going to this
summer you know to take him on without
having it you know having that cleared
up if he's gonna be able to return and
be the player that that he was and was
was heading kind of kind of trending to
be and so it's it's tough I mean they've
got there's this huge crop of free
agents right and and sort of none of
them are slated as of now set to wind up
in LA you know the name you never hear
about anymore is Jimmy Butler it's
almost like he's been kind of lost is
the the Sixers beefed up their roster
you know maybe he's the guy they look at
but you know a lot comes back with
Anthony Davis if they can't trade for
him then you have to wonder like well
whoever does get them next year
is it a one-year rental yeah assuming
that it's a contender that gets them
that it's kind of hard to imagine that
so then if you're the Lakers you have to
I think probably look at spending some
of your your cap space and try to make a
trade or two to get better and just move
on in a different way talking to Joe
Vardhan he is a senior NBA writer
for the athletic joining us Dan Patrick
show do you think the Lakers regret
bringing in LeBron too early to say oh
no III don't think so
III think in this something I've been
I've been chewing on I just you know the
Lakers were run by Magic Johnson who
himself was a star and and then the
general manager is Rob pálinka who was
Kobe's agent so between those two they
feel like they had ample experience with
kind of a transcendent star in the
middle of the team I still don't feel
like they kind of I I don't feel like
they had done enough to really
understand LeBron and and what it's like
to to run a team with him and I just I
don't I think the evidence is pretty
clear just based on how they built the
roster and what they said at the
beginning of the year which was what
we're not we're trying to avoid what
what Cleveland was you know Cleveland
and Miami before it was where
organizations that put largely
specialists and other really good
players around LeBron and took like the
most advanced like took advantage of
what of what LeBron does best now this
isn't to say that LeBron wasn't
complicit in how this roster was was put
together he was but I think it's more of
the style of play
you know the LeBron wanted more
playmakers it's true he wanted other
people to be able to handle the ball
it's true but everything of course when
this works well runs through him and of
course he's the one who generates the
offense and that's kind of not how the
Lakers play I mean yeah he's their
leading scorer but they were more of
just uh whoever hasn't get out and runs
as if they led the league in pace I
think for a while or was were right up
there and and and that was kind of I
think that that was like a real thing
that you can point to that they just
didn't do enough to kind of understand
what works well with LeBron I mean the
Cavs
he did this a certain way and got the
eight straight finals now the Lakers
probably weren't going to make it to a
finals anyway but I think they probably
should have stuck more to the same
recipe that did the last two teams that
have LeBron used it it works pretty well
I'll leave you with this with Golden
State losing again last night
you can see at one point if you're a
lip-reader Steve Curt has a disparaging
comment about draymond Green we've had
the drama with Kevin Durant klay
Thompson has been injured they just sort
of they must hate the regular season and
I know they can turn it on and off Joe
but you know here we go again you blow a
lead if you lose it home to Phoenix and
then klay Thompson said hey we need the
fans to be excited about this if the
players aren't excited about playing
Phoenix why should the fans be is there
any concern here and the Rockets are
playing well maybe Boston's figured out
something a you know is it still Golden
State's NBA yeah you know if they want
to win this or not yeah it is the
regular season and this is this is a
problem for the NBA but but the regular
season is just it's largely meaningless
and and you know I think it'll be that
way until the Warriors kind of break up
but yeah I mean there's I see no real
concern based off of what happened last
night or what's been happening this year
I think what will be interesting is to
see how they manage DeMarcus Cousins in
matchups against teams that are smaller
and can switch in the Celtics being one
of them and I had a potential finals but
you know like just about this thing with
the regular season you know I spent some
time with Kyrie last week in LA and and
one of the things that we discussed that
he's kind of relearning kind of
re-remember is just how long and silly
and stupid the NBA regular season can be
and all this stuff happens all year
especially if you have a star Laden team
like the Celtics or the Warriors and
that's all it is just fluff it's just
outside noise and when you get
the playoffs and you can strategize for
a series and you can put the ball in
your star's hands and all the
possessions matter it's just a different
it's a different sport and you know the
Warriors clearly have the experience
they clearly have the talent you know
they have the confidence they have they
have the it so yeah this is their league
prohibitive favorites coming in for sure
thank you Joe good to catch up with you
again and have fun at the athletic
that's a Jove Arden one of their lead
NBA writers am Patrick show brought to
you by mercedes-amg be prepared for
whatever comes your way the all-new GT
4-door coupe because life's a race visit
your local dealership for a test drive
today by the way if you missed any of
the interviews from this program the
Mercedes AMG mancave just go to the Dan
Patrick show app where you can watch
listen from inside the Mercedes AMG
mancave Mercedes AMG driving performance
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]